es un descontento que parece no cesar a
medida que los niveles de pobreza y las
condiciones de vida precarias se
mantienen en argentina la población
exige acciones por parte del gobierno
una demanda con la que los argentinos
inundaron las calles de buenos aires
tamacá lo mismo que marchamos en el país
hace un mes que es por trabajo genuino
contra la pobreza del hambre
no hemos tenido ninguna respuesta de la
marcha federal tuvimos diferentes
reuniones con el gobierno la verdad que
fueron todas insatisfactoria y es que en
el país que roza el 60 por ciento de
inflación anual mucha gente está
aguantando hambre como dicen los
argentinos con una tasa de pobreza del
más del 37 por ciento los ciudadanos
exigen una mayor asistencia a los
comedores sociales y a las familias
mientras los precios de los alimentos y
otros productos básicos siguen
aumentando
[Música]
alimentos para 400 millones de personas
aquí somos 47 millones
en su mesa una precariedad a la que
ahora se le suma el rechazo al nuevo
acuerdo con el fmi para refinanciar un
préstamo que pidió el gobierno de
mauricio macri en 2018 porque la
situación social en argentina se agrava
a partir del ajuste y el acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional que el
gobierno ha firmado
estableciendo prioridades
que no son las del pueblo argentino
según cáritas y la universidad católica
nacional uno de cada diez argentinos
pasa hambre cotidianamente una situación
insostenible para muchos